The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So today,
we're going to talk about
non-renewable sources--
boring, dull, fossil stuff.
The main reason for
talking about this stuff
is it's really important.
It's about 92% of
US primary energy.
And if you look global, and you
look just at marketed energy,
forgetting gathered
wood and related stuff,
it's also about 92%.
And this is an EIA
graph that basically
shows the evolution of primary
energy supply from 1850
to 2000 or 2010.
The point of this graph
is it changes slowly.
1850 is all wood
and a little coal.
Coal gets big, coal shrinks,
coal's still important.
Oil's nothing, oil gets very
big, hasn't shrunk much.
And renewables--
with a good glass,
you can kind of
see them up here.
So these things change slowly.
Fossil markets are important.
They will continue
to be important.
What I'm going to do
is a little bit theory,
because you have to hear
about Hotelling when
we talk about non-renewable
natural resources,
and then talk about why
Hotelling doesn't quite work,
but why the key
insight holds, and then
just go through some markets.
So I'll start natural gas today.
I'm going to finish
it up on Wednesday,
Wednesday, I want to have
a discussion basically
on fracking, and its related
technologies and implications.
If you look at the readings,
there are some pros, some cons,
some neutral.
It is probably the
biggest energy development
in my lifetime, and it has lots
of pluses and minuses, which
I hope we can explore a
bit, which we won't resolve.
They'll be resolved
in your lifetimes,
but this is a big deal, not
just in the US where I'll focus,
but globally.
So the Hotelling decision,
the Hotelling theory,
is pretty straightforward.
You imagine you have 1,000
barrels of oil in the ground.
You have a valve.
You can pump it out whenever
you choose to pump it out.
It costs you $30 a
barrel to pump it out.
And you can produce
it whenever you want.
The price of oil
today is $80 a barrel.
If you know the future,
this theory says,
how do you decide
when to produce?
Brendan.
AUDIENCE: You just
choose the days
when the oil prices are
the highest per barrel.
I mean, the oil per barrel
price is the highest.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
want to discount, maybe?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you might
want to maximize
discounted net revenue.
Marginal cost is the
same, by assumption.
So yeah, you'd want
to maximize that.
So you choose a time T or a
set of T's, if they're are all
equivalent, and pump it out.
Is that clear?
That's sort of how you decide.
You've got a choice of time now.
So you look period by period.
You say, when is the good time?
You'd pump it out then.
Now, the interesting
question is,
suppose the whole
world looks like this.
Suppose everybody's got an
oil well exactly like yours.
What has to happen
to the price of oil?
Kirsten, want to take a shot?
What's the price
of oil have to do?
AUDIENCE: It has to
respond to demand.
If all the oil wells
are exactly the same,
then you're assuming
that [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, I'm sitting here.
I have 1,000 barrels
in the ground.
Everybody's got 1,000
barrels in the ground.
There are a lot of us,
so it's competitive.
And I have perfect foresight.
I can see where the
price of oil is going.
So if that market with
all of us with wells
like that and a known
demand curve, let's say,
is going to be in equilibrium,
what has to happen to price?
OK, let me push
you a little bit.
Suppose the price today--
suppose it's two periods,
and call that thing up there
"discounted net price."
Suppose discounted net
price today is higher than
discounted net price tomorrow.
When do I produce?
AUDIENCE: Today.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Today.
And if we're
identical and we all
produce today, what
happens to today's price?
AUDIENCE: Goes down.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Goes down,
so it probably isn't going
to be higher than tomorrow's.
Suppose it's lower
than tomorrow's.
What do we all do?
AUDIENCE: Wait till tomorrow.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And if we all wait--
AUDIENCE: Then it goes down.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
If we all wait,
then today's price goes up,
because nobody's producing.
If it's equal to
tomorrow's, then we sort of
don't care when we produce.
And it kind of can be
in equilibrium then,
if it's equal.
But if it's not equal, it
can't be an equilibrium
between the two days.
Everybody see that?
If the discounted net price
is different in two periods,
it can't be in equilibrium,
because either you'll
switch out of one or you'll
switch into the other,
and that'll upset the price.
So if today's price is low,
if I expect the price to rise
rapidly, I won't produce.
Neither will anybody else.
Today's price won't be
low if nobody's producing.
That's not an equilibrium.
If today's price is high
relative to my expectations
tomorrow, I'm going to produce.
And if we all produce,
it can't stay high.
The only way you can
have an equilibrium
is if this quantity,
price minus marginal cost,
rises at the rate of interest.
If that rises at the
rate of interest,
then I don't care
when I produce.
Basically the other way to
think about it, that I think
maybe is the most
useful, is I've
got a choice between leaving
the oil in the ground
and leaving my
money in the bank,
hypothetically getting
interest rate R. Sorry,
I have a choice between
leaving the oil in the ground
and getting whatever I get based
on the future price of oil,
or pumping the oil out and
putting the money in the bank.
So I can either invest
in oil or in the bank.
And unless those two are equal,
I won't be in equilibrium.
And the mechanism I went
through with Kirsten
is if you're out of equilibrium,
if this equality doesn't hold
for all t, then we will, all
of us in a competitive market,
make changes in production
decisions that move you
in the direction of equilibrium.
So if tomorrow's price is
low relative to today's, we
produce today, which
lowers today's prices,
so that can't be an equilibrium.
If today's price is low
relative to tomorrow,
we all wait, which
raises today's price.
Only if that equality
holds do we not
have an incentive, all of us, to
shift production dramatically.
So it's investing.
It's leaving it in the
oil versus leaving it
in the ground versus
putting it in the bank.
If those two aren't
equal, you readjust.
Is that pretty
straightforward at this stage?
OK, one thing that's
interesting about this story
is you'll notice that price
is above marginal cost
everywhere, even though
by assumption it's
a competitive market.
How can that be?
Well, that's because
when you produce today,
you incur not only the
marginal production costs,
but you incur an
opportunity cost.
With only 1,000 barrels,
if I produce today,
I lose the chance of producing
that barrel in the future.
So part of the cost
of producing today
is that opportunity cost, which
is why the equilibrium has
price above marginal cost.
If price is equal to
marginal cost at all times,
nobody's going to produce.
Why would I produce today, given
that prices might be better
tomorrow, blah, blah, blah?
So that's the basic
Hotelling story--
that under competitive
conditions,
price rises at the
rate of interest.
This is the usual
picture with time.
Price minus marginal
cost rises at the rate
of interest or simply enough--
with the given
demand curve, you're
basically running
up the demand curve
until you run out
of whatever it is.
And this has quantity on the
axis and this time on the axis,
so that you can't go immediately
from one to the other,
but you see the point.
And for simple cases, you
can just write it out.
You can solve the equations.
So under these
assumptions, it doesn't
matter when you produce
the oil if you're
a competitor, because
all these have
the same discounted net revenue.
And if a monopoly has all the
oil and you're a competitor,
you might want to
produce now because what
the monopolist will do
will have marginal revenue
minus marginal cost rise
at the interest rate.
And if that doesn't make sense
to you, don't worry about it.
We're not coming back to it.
So you may want
to produce today.
Now, this is a
really nice theory.
This is very elegant.
It's very simple.
I didn't have to wave
my hands too rapidly,
I think, to explain it.
There's only one tiny
problem with it--
prices don't rise at
the rate of interest.
These are oil prices.
These are 2010 dollars,
so the lighter line
is the real price of oil.
And that is not a smooth curve
rising at the rate of interest
at any time in any place.
So the first thing
you have to ask
is, is that theory fundamentally
crazy or is it too simplified
by a bit?
And the answer is, I
think, it's too simplified.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about what it leaves out,
without trying to do anything
more complex than that.
It's important.
So there are a bunch of
things it leaves out.
I think the most important
one is exploration,
because you don't have 1,000
barrels in your well ever.
You don't know what you've got.
If you think about--
just focus on oil--
you look for promising geology.
You explore it.
You drill to prove the reserves.
You refine your estimates.
A former teacher of mine
just said Hotelling is wrong.
It's not a tank of
oil, it's an inventory.
As an oil company,
you build inventory,
and then you run down inventory.
So reserves at any time are the
result of a set of decisions.
But the decisions have
this same dimension.
When do you explore?
When do you invest?
When do you lease a tract?
When do you drill?
How many wells do you drill?
Those are all when decisions.
Those are all
intratemporal decisions.
And you have to think about
today's price and tomorrow's
price.
And if you think today's
price is really low
and tomorrow's price is
going to be better, you wait.
If you think today's
prices are high
and you can get the oil out
in a hurry, you move ahead.
So this same notion that's
in the simple model, that
says I've got to think
about the path of price
to make decisions,
holds true, but these
are much more
complicated decisions.
and in the face of uncertainty,
because you don't really
know reserves or demand
or anything else.
And interesting little number--
from proved reserves, you
can look up a definition,
but it means reasonably likely
you can get that oil out
at commercial costs.
So from the end of 1976
to the end of 2009,
proved oil reserves in the US
fell by 10.26 billion barrels.
How much do you think was
produced over that period?
How many of you think more
than 20 billion barrels
was produced over that period?
Reserves fell by 10.26.
How many think that over
that period, more than 20
were produced?
OK, how many over 30?
Anybody think over 40?
78 and a half--
continuing process of
exploration, discovery,
proving the reserves,
expanding the field,
investing in recovery.
Reserves are an inventory.
You still have to decide
when, some cases if.
You can lease a tract
that you can drill in.
You may decide not to drill.
You have a certain
amount of time.
You decide not to
pick up the option.
But all these decisions are
when decisions, but that's
why we're going to run out of
oil because reserves are low.
Reserves are always low.
This is the point.
There's no point in building
up huge reserves, which
is an activity of exploration,
and investment, and discovery,
and so forth.
There's no point building
up reserves you're not
going to need for 50 years.
Why make that investment now?
So that's one story.
Exploration is a big story.
It involves a lot of
when decisions, just
like the simple model.
The other part of the
story is depletion.
And depletion operates
at two levels--
a given oil field will
eventually stop producing.
You will have all the oil out.
But a given geographic
region like the US,
it gets harder and harder.
There's a reason
we're drilling miles
off the coast in the Gulf
of Mexico and miles down.
The first wells in
Pennsylvania, the oil
was coming out of the ground.
They basically used buckets.
It's a little harder now.
Cost rises.
The other side of
the coin, of course,
is that we're
getting better at it.
And people in the oil business
talk about the price of oil
as a race between
depletion and innovation.
It's harder to find it.
It's harder to get
it out of the ground.
We're getting better at finding
it and better at getting it out
of the ground.
There's no guarantee that
technology wins that race.
So far it's done quite well, but
these massive things offshore--
we'll see how far that goes.
And of course, you don't know.
But one of the things--
you don't know the
supply, demand,
what competitors are doing.
So a lot of the fluctuations
in price you see
are due to just uncertainty.
People misguess.
There is a recession.
The demand falls.
There's a sudden, boom that
people hadn't anticipated.
Demand rises.
And particularly in oil, where
we spend a fair amount of time,
there isn't much flexibility.
It's not quite like
that Hotelling model
where you basically
have a valve.
When you've drilled and
there's pressure in the field,
you tend not to shut a well in.
That has a variety
of consequences.
So in the short run-- and
it's expensive to store oil.
I mean, you store it.
It is stored, but it's not
stored in gigantic quantity.
So there's relatively
inelastic supply.
When we talked
about demand curves,
we talked about relatively
inelastic demand.
And that means you've got
a steep supply curve--
let's see-- a steep supply
curve and a steep demand curve.
And when they move,
price is very volatile.
At the risk of-- well, there's
no eraser so I'm saved having
to use the blackboard, but
imagine a steep demand curve
and a steep supply curve--
little fluctuations move price.
Thank you.
And of course, it's not
a competitive market.
There's OPEC.
OPEC has a variety
of motivations
that are complicated.
And modeling and trying
to understand OPEC,
people make nice livings
trying to do that.
So that's sort of
what's missing.
Oh, and of course, politics.
Why in heaven's name would
you drill miles deep,
miles offshore, when
you can produce oil
in Saudi Arabia for
$3 or $4 a barrel?
Why are we spending
these and doing
these incredible feats of
technology, risky technology?
And the answer is, it's
not a unified world market
politically.
OK, comments about any of that?
Questions about any of that?
OK, I'm now going to, to the
extent that time permits,
sort of walk through.
Prosper, did you have your
hand up or were you just--
thought it was up here.
I didn't know.
OK, I'm now going to just
walk through these markets--
first oil, then coal, then
uranium, and then I'll
start natural gas.
Oil, again, some basic facts,
some numbers, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, the key thing--
I was told this years ago, that
the key thing to pass yourself
off as an energy
economist, the key number
you need to without fail--
write this down--
42 gallons in a barrel.
That's the number, 42
gallons in a barrel--
very esoteric.
That's the number, 42 gallons.
Oil is a global market.
It's best model is a pool.
Supply goes in the pool,
demand comes out of the pool.
It's moved by
pipelines and tankers.
Tankers can change
direction in mid-ocean.
They often do.
Active markets, spot
market, futures markets--
it's there are good data
on all of these markets.
During the first Gulf War,
it was a source of some--
there were a lot
of people saying
we should shut down the futures
markets because the futures
markets were
showing high prices.
Because oil was
tough because Iraq
had suddenly come
off the market.
The argument that won the
day against shutting down
the futures market was
that the futures market
was predicting a rapid
decline in the price of oil.
You could do a term structure.
You could say, what
does the market
predict January, February,
March, April, and so forth?
And the futures
market was saying,
we expect this to
be a short war.
And it was possible to make--
I was one of those who made it--
the argument that why would you
shut off something that is,
in fact, A, useful, and B,
providing exactly the signal
that you want to send--
that it'll be a short war.
So very, very active
markets, global.
The production is
concentrated, as we know,
a lot of it in unstable places.
OPEC is a complicated cartel.
Saudi Arabia has
been the big player,
and about the only
holder of excess capacity
for most of the period.
And price has been volatile.
So let me elaborate
a little bit.
International oil trade in 2010
was about 65% of production.
So about 65% of world
production crossed
an international border.
And if you look at
the big numbers here--
that's a big number,
that's a big number, that's
a big number--
the big sources are Russian
oil going mainly to Europe,
but also some to China--
Russian oil.
Middle Eastern oil
going everywhere,
including to the US.
Canadian oil coming to the US.
In fact, Venezuelan
oil coming to the US.
But importantly, the Mid East,
if you add up those numbers,
that's a lot of numbers.
And you add up, look
at the Russian numbers,
they're pretty significant.
Globally, the Middle
East is about 30%.
This is not a great chart, but
the Middle East is this bar.
It's about 30% of
world production.
It's over half of
proved reserves.
So this is reserves over time.
And this is a nice graph.
All these things are
from the BP Statistical
Report, which is--
again, you can't read it,
but it's a good reference.
Look first at how global
reserves have expanded,
and they've continued to
expand for a long time.
Global reserves have
gone up by almost 40%
between 1990 and 2010.
The Middle East still
has over half, 54.4.
Its share has declined
from 66 to 54.
So people are exploring.
And they're exploring
outside the Middle East,
as well as inside
the Middle East,
which is why the Middle
Eastern share has declined.
This is OPEC's
share of the world
market over time, world output.
And it has varied.
These are the countries
in the Persian Gulf,
including Saudi Arabia,
that offloads into the Gulf.
In reaction to the
first energy shock,
you got lots of
investment outside OPEC
to expand capacity.
And OPEC's share of output fell.
It rose again.
This runs out in
1997, and I haven't
seen a graph that
continues, but it
will have declined since 1997.
But it's varied.
It's varied over time.
Even at 30%, OPEC
had the ability
to make a significant
difference to world prices.
Again, short-run supply,
inelastic, short-run demand,
inelastic, very
steep demand curve.
Change supply a little
bit, you can move price.
So OPEC has had that ability.
This is the final oil slide.
This makes a point.
It's really important
to keep in mind
when you listen to the media.
This is a ranking of--
it's 2007 is the
latest I could find,
but it's companies ranked
by worldwide reserves.
And the key thing is
there is ExxonMobil.
ExxonMobil that we think of as
this giant company on the world
market is, on the world
market, not a giant company.
There's Saudi,
there's Iran, there's
Qatar, which is mostly
gas, but there's Iraq,
there's Venezuela, there's
Abu Dhabi, there's Kuwait.
And you have to come
pretty far down--
and those are all
government companies.
Those are all
state-owned enterprises,
creatures of the government.
You've got to come pretty
far down before you get--
and there is Gazprom, Nigeria,
Kuwait, PetroChina, even.
You've got to come pretty
far down before you
get to ExxonMobil.
The Brazilian firm has
just found a huge oil field
off Brazil.
So that will come up.
The big companies are
government companies.
The big players are governments.
It's a single world market.
Questions about oil?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the
Middle East reserves
have declined as a proportion.
Do you think it's
because they just
don't have an incentive to
explore now, they have so much?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, they have explored.
I think they're just
not as aggressive.
Model them as a monopoly
facing competitors.
They might not be aggressive.
They still have a pretty
commanding position--
over half of reserves, running
now about 30% of production.
I think they're just
not being as aggressive.
I mean, you're not
drilling miles offshore
in the Persian Gulf.
You're drilling miles
offshore in Louisiana.
So you're drilling
in the North Sea
in very difficult conditions.
The Saudis don't have to
do that, and they don't.
They could be more aggressive.
I don't know if there's
anything in the Persian Gulf,
but there are big fields
that aren't being pushed.
But this isn't trivial.
They have expanded
their reserves.
And they've obviously
produced a lot in this period,
as well as expanding
reserves, so they're not just
sitting there.
But they're less aggressive.
Question about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I don't know
if [INAUDIBLE] the oil price.
Would you happen to know the
volatility of the oil price
compared to, I don't know,
the stock market volatility?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, it's
really fascinating, isn't it?
I mean, when you go back here--
so this is in dollars, not
inflation-corrected dollars.
So there's this long period.
Yeah, it's volatile when
you take it up to 2010,
but this is--
we've lost the axis-- this
is between $1, $2, and $3
down here.
So this is between $1 and $3.
I guess it's fairly volatile,
but frankly, $3 a barrel
for oil, 42 gallons, $3
for half that in gasoline,
and then distribution
charges, not a big deal.
This is hard to match, the
spike at $80 and the spike that
we're still debating
in 2008, I guess,
or 2007, whichever
one that hit in.
I forget.
That's just remarkably volatile.
This one we understand.
That was politics.
That was a huge supply cut.
This appears to be a
significant, unanticipated
increase in demand with very
inelastic short-run supply.
But it is still being debated.
There are people who say,
well that must be speculation.
And you say, well, yeah,
but if you bought oil
at those high prices,
you took delivery.
People actually got the stuff.
People were taking
delivery at these prices.
That isn't paper.
That's barrels of oil
coming off a tanker.
So it's hard to tell a
speculative story, I think.
I think it's supply
and demand, but you're
right-- that's just that's
as volatile as anything
you're ever going to see.
And nobody expects
volatility to go back
to all these good, old days
because the politics haven't
gotten any simpler.
If there is a war in Iran, you
will see a heck of a spike.
And in fact, we and the
Europeans and others
are in the process of putting
sanctions on Iran designed
to limit their exports.
Well, if the Saudis
don't pick up the slack,
we'll see another spike.
We'll see.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: So the cost of
production was $3, $4?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I'm making up a number,
but the cost of production
in the Middle East
is well below the market price.
AUDIENCE: And I'm just
wondering if it's $5,
and the cost of a barrel
of oil is $100 [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, remember, the price
is always going to be
above marginal production
cost because of the
opportunity cost argument.
So that's not a big surprise.
And the low-cost producers
in the Middle East
are not behaving like
pure competitors.
They're restricting output.
So yeah, there was a time
when the price of oil
was, I don't know--
well, look here-- when the price
of oil in the '73 shock went up
to-- and I think it--
I can't quite read this.
Oh, this is some sort of blended
price, which I don't quite get.
But the price of oil quadrupled.
The cost of oil
didn't quadruple.
And it stayed high.
Look at the money of the day,
which is where we all live.
It went up dramatically.
Oh, you know what
the problem is?
I think this is in--
what is it dollars per--
yes, I never understood.
No, it's per barrel, OK.
I thought it was per
ton of oil equivalent.
But the price quadrupled
in a few months.
And the cost didn't.
That was pure market power.
And if they were making
money at these prices,
they were making a lot
of money at those prices.
The journals were full of
articles about recycling
petrodollars, and
where were they
going to invest
them, and so forth.
They managed to manage to
figure out ways to waste them,
so that was all solved.
But yeah, that's--
And the cost now, who knows what
the cost of production is now?
There's also a number that
you see floating around.
It's called the "finding cost."
There's one thing is the cost
of drilling and getting it out
of the ground.
The other is the
cost of finding it,
which is the exploration,
and proving, and so forth.
And those costs
have gone up a bit.
The cost of producing it out
of an big known Saudi reserve
is turning a valve,
almost, short run.
Long run, you've
got to-- medium run,
you've got to put the
piping and stuff in.
Long run, you've got to find it.
Medium run, cost pretty
low, well below price--
not off Louisiana.
That's not far below the price.
That's expensive stuff.
So you have a range of costs.
You have a range of
behaviors in this market.
Anything else on oil,
questions on oil?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did the
sanctions on Iran
have an effect on the
supply and demand.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What
would have an effect?
AUDIENCE: The sanctions on Iran
because when Iran sells it,
it can, pretty much,
with a phone call,
go anywhere else in the world.
Really, is it--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
don't know the answer.
I know the problem is, if
we don't buy oil from Iran,
who cares?
Because they can sell to
other people and they'll
just displace other suppliers.
So this was like when the
Arabs refused to sell oil
to the US in the '70s.
We had been buying from them.
We bought from others.
And their oil went to
others, and so forth.
If the US, and the EU,
and Japan, let's say,
have effective refusals
to buy Iranian oil, that's
enough that it might be hard for
them to find demand elsewhere.
It gets to be a
quantitative question.
If we can block
enough exits for them,
they may have a hard
time selling it.
The question is, who buys then?
So I just don't know
whether it's had an effect
or whether people really think
it's going to have an effect.
There are a lot of people--
I mean, a lot of
the other sanctions
have had an effect on Iran.
You read discussions about
living in Iran these days.
It's not very good.
The economy is pretty
much in the toilet,
but how much of that's
the oil sanctions
and how much is everything else
we've done, I just don't know.
OK.
Anything else?
Yeah, Scott.
AUDIENCE: Can we go back to
the slide with the picture
where the oil from different
countries are going?
I had a question
about something.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah-- not quickly.
There.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So it looks like the oil from
the US is going into Mexico,
and then the oil from
Mexico is going into the US.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
there's a little border trade.
It's not a big number.
AUDIENCE: So is that
because it's cheaper
to buy oil from Mexico than
to produce it ourselves?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
some of it is just geography.
I mean, I'm little
surprised by that.
You always see it
in the numbers,
that we're exporting
something to somebody.
It must be-- and some of this
is refined product rather than
crude.
So yeah, maybe we
have a refinery here
that it makes sense to export
refined product to Monterrey.
And they happen to have--
I don't know where they're--
I don't think they have
any fields up here.
I'm not sure what
they're exporting to us,
but I'm assuming that some
of this is refined product.
I don't know why would
be shipping crude.
And I talk about
this as if it's easy,
but this is pipeline,
the US-Mexico's pipeline.
It's almost
certainly not tanker.
And of course, it's
where are the pipelines,
where are the demands.
You could imagine as
Monterrey grows in Mexico,
it might be cheaper
since it's in the north.
It might be cheaper to supply
it from the southern US
than from farther
south in Mexico.
And maybe this is tanker.
Maybe they put stuff and
take it to the West Coast.
I don't know, but
you've got to figure
this has as much to do with
transport costs, pipeline
location, shipping
cost, refineries,
as getting it out of the ground.
Mexico has a little
bit of a problem.
Mexico has a constitutional
bar against foreigners
owning natural resources.
And that means they've operated
with a state-owned oil company
since the 1911--
no, since the 1930s
when they kicked out
the foreigners completely.
And the state-owned oil
company has been inefficient
and has had a hard time
getting technology.
So they're facing
production declines,
and facing
constitutional problems
of how do you bring
in foreign technology.
So it's sort of an
interesting question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry, just
to throw some light on that.
When I worked at JPM
on the crude oil desk,
one of the things they
used to always talk about
was the geographic difference
between a defense district
called PAD 5 over there, which
includes all of the West Coast.
And there's severe
geographical limitations
that don't allow oil to
actually be transported.
So they actually trade
completely differently
in terms of oil pricing.
And because a lot of our oil
comes from Cushing, Oklahoma,
which is like that
central point over there,
they might have to exchange
it across international lines,
even if it's crude oil.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You think
it might be refined in Mexico
and brought back as product.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, that's a nice point.
They're called PADs, or
Petroleum Allocation Districts,
or something like that.
It's a Cold War term, I think.
AUDIENCE: Defense district
also included somewhere.
It was created during wartime.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, I think
that's a World War II thing.
It's not real easy
to pump anything
across the Rocky Mountains.
And so the West Coast tends
to operate separately.
Alaskan oil tends
to come down here,
even though it'd be better
to sell it to Japan.
And of course, Canadian oil--
you know the Keystone
Pipeline debate,
if you've been following it.
Where Canadian oil goes is
another interesting question.
But yeah, that's interesting.
It may be that it's cheaper to
get Mexican oil into California
than to get oil from
elsewhere in the US,
and that some US oil--
this is the puzzler,
that we're shipping.
It may be to be
refined in Mexico.
It may be refined product
into the north of Mexico
if they're short of
refinery capacity.
AUDIENCE: I think the
oil pipelines go straight
into Cushing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They might not
be able to even reverse
the flow, which they've
actually been doing recently.
But back then, maybe,
when this was made,
they weren't able to reverse it.
So they have to move it and
then actually physically
bring it around.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, these are 2010.
these are 2010 data.
So--
AUDIENCE: I think the reversal
happened just this year.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: This year.
OK, happy to learn.
Anything else?
OK, let me go to coal.
Coal is concentrated.
As that earlier case indicated,
we're probably the OPEC of coal
or the Saudi Arabia of coal.
It is traded.
Coal trades
internationally, and I'll
show you some numbers on that.
But it has a high
weight to value ratio.
So it's not quite as
easy to handle as oil
and it's not quite
as valuable as oil.
So it's like international
trade in rocks.
There is some, but
there isn't that much
because it's expensive.
Markets are mainly national.
There are some differences.
We tend to have lower
prices than elsewhere.
This isn't a business where
there are a lot of spot markets
and futures markets.
There are some, but it's
mostly long-term contracts.
And the world fact is this
unbelievable recent increase
in the Chinese use of coal
that we talked about earlier--
"unbelievable" is the
wrong term, but it's huge.
I have to say I revised this
from last year's lecture.
And the Chinese numbers
are dramatically different.
It's kind of shocking.
This is production and reserves.
So you will see we have over
a quarter of the world's coal
reserves.
China sort of comes in--
well, Russia comes
in second at 18%.
China comes in third, but look
at that-- the Chinese produce
almost half the coal in
the world, 48% as of 2010.
That's a number that
deserves to be in red.
It was somewhere in the 20s
the last time I did this.
Well, I did it two years ago,
so somewhere in the 20s or 30s.
But it's relatively
concentrated.
These five countries
account for 80% of output
and three-quarters of reserves.
Again, these are
reserves, of course.
Does that mean we've looked for
coal everywhere in the world?
No.
Does that mean there
isn't a lot of coal
in places we haven't looked?
No.
But we've looked
in these places,
and we found a lot of it
in the US and a lot of it
in China and Russia.
There may be some--
people talk about
coal in Africa,
but there hasn't been
that much exploration.
Only about 15% of
production of coal
crosses international lines.
So it really isn't like oil.
These are the big exporters.
And I didn't add up the
shares, but you can do that.
We do export out of both coasts,
but I think mostly the East
Coast to Europe.
The big exporters, though,
are Australia and Indonesia.
And if you look at who
the big importers are,
you can see immediately
where it goes.
Not only does China
produce a lot of coal,
but they're the second-leading
importer of coal.
So you have Australian
and Indonesian coal
going, to a decent
approximation, China, Japan,
and South Korea--
again, fairly concentrated.
Expensive, not cheap to ship
this stuff, but huge demands.
Japan has no energy.
China has coal, but
China needs more coal
than it can produce
in the short run.
So that's the flow.
I don't have a good picture.
Not a world market.
You can't read this
well, but these are
Japanese prices in this column.
Those are the ones that matter.
Either column, you
will see they're
higher than the US
prices typically.
And the European prices are a
bit higher than the US prices
typically.
You can't do that for oil.
The price of oil
is pretty uniform.
But you can for coal.
And this is the graph
that's shocking.
This is world coal use.
You see it rising gently
and then exploding.
And if you look
behind that picture,
the explosion is mostly China.
In the US, it's worth
looking at states.
Production is
fairly concentrated.
Wyoming coal is mined mostly
big strip-mining operations,
massive strip-mining operations,
close to the surface.
Surface is taken off.
You go down.
You strip away a layer of coal.
This coal tends to
have a low sulfur
content, the Western
coal, the Wyoming coal.
So it's less polluting
on that dimension.
There is a mix of low-
and high-sulfur coal
in these main mining regions
in the East, West Virginia,
Kentucky, and Pennsylvania.
So those five states account
for almost three-quarters
of production.
Consumption is much
less concentrated.
This is for power
plants, but that's
almost all coal consumption--
Texas, Ohio-- these
are the states
with cheap electric
rates because they
burn a lot of coal.
I got anything else on coal?
Yeah, that's about it on coal.
Questions, comments,
reactions about coal?
Not the most
exciting of products,
but very important and dirty--
not to be prejudicial.
Anything?
OK, I'll say a little
bit about uranium.
There isn't much that you
can find about uranium--
essentially nothing
in the BP book.
And I'm focusing on uranium
rather than nuclear power
because that's the
nonrenewable part, is uranium.
But it's also
relatively unimportant.
I mean, it's not an
important component
of the cost of
nuclear electricity.
It does seem to be
a global market.
I'll explain that
in a little bit.
Reserves are fairly dispersed.
I mean, again, not clear there's
been extensive exploration
in lots of these places.
You remember the
yellowcake from Niger,
very exciting in the run-up
to the second Gulf War.
I had a price graph.
It's not very interesting.
It's mostly long-term prices.
They're are just flat
from the mid '80s
through the mid '90s,
or the early '80s
through the mid '90s.
And then they began to escalate.
And basically in
that early period,
people just stopped
producing uranium.
And now they've tripled.
There's new mining activity.
There's really no
organized market
as there is for oil, or even
to some extent for coal.
These are long-term contracts.
There's a spot market.
It's not very interesting.
It's very thin.
We import almost all of the
uranium we use in US reactors--
92%, a lot of it from
Australia and Canada,
and then from Russia and
a couple of the 'Stans.
And production is more
concentrated than reserves,
so those countries
have 93% of production.
Kazakhstan is a big producer,
Canada, Australia, and then
it falls off relatively rapidly.
We account for about 3%
of global production.
So not a terribly exciting,
not a terribly big market.
Anything about uranium?
This is fairly boring
stuff, but you sort of
do need to have some basic
factual understanding of what
these markets look
like if you're going
to be in the energy business.
Let me do gas.
Gas is more interesting.
You may at some
point have wondered
why we call it "natural gas."
It's not all that obvious, but
it's because beginning in 1816
we produced gas from coal.
I don't know how
early in Europe,
but in this country in 1816.
You heat coal.
It gives off gas.
You put the gas in a pipe.
You ship it around the city
and use it for lighting.
That was gas.
Natural gas was the
innovation-- that you
didn't produce it from coal.
You got it naturally,
hence "natural gas."
It can be moved by pipeline.
To move it by ship, you
have to liquefy it, cool it,
and compress it.
It is not a global market.
As we'll talk about next
time, that might change--
lots of interesting
discussions there.
That might change.
This is circa 2010.
This will change.
We produce about 85%
of the gas we consume.
Most of the rest is from
Canada, so North America
is pretty much
self-sufficient in gas.
Most of our imports--
no, it's not on this slide.
The way the prices
work, US prices
tend to be below
European prices.
European prices are determined
by Russian gas prices,
and they're much lower
than Asian prices,
because Asia's gas tends to
come via liquefied natural gas,
which is expensive.
Historically, if I were
doing this-- well, when
I did this class two years
ago, this sort of stopped here.
Gas reserves are
associated with oil.
They tend to be in
politically unstable places.
The gas we know most about is in
unstable regions in the Middle
East and, if you think
it's unstable, Russia.
But that has
changed dramatically
in literally the last
three or four years.
Shale gas can be produced
cheaply, not necessarily
without environmental
costs, but cheaply.
And once again, the US is
lucky-- we have a lot of it.
We now have the ability
to produce a lot of gas
cheaply with environmental
costs, potentially.
We think China has
that same ability.
Some European countries do.
We're told it's under Paris.
Paris is resisting drilling--
makes a good story,
even if it's not true.
Might be true.
I want to focus on this change
on Wednesday, because as I say,
this is the biggest
energy change, certainly
in my lifetime.
Well, maybe OPEC
was bigger, but it's
close to OPEC in terms of a
change in the energy landscape.
But what we do about it is
subject to serious debate.
And I want to try to
outline that and get
you to engage a little bit.
There are those who
say we should not
be using this technology.
New York State
does not allow it.
North Dakota
eagerly embraces it,
is thrilled to have
jobs, actually, in North
Dakota, and boomtowns, and cheap
liquor, and everything else--
all the other good things
that come with a boomtown.
But as a country,
we have some issues.
There's a question of its
impact on climate change.
You sort of think cheap
gas would be good,
but what if it leaks?
So I want to spend
next time on that.
Today, I want to just
go through some sort
of pre-fracking facts, if
I can say that, and lay
the groundwork.
So this is gas trade.
Most of it-- well, 70% of
it-- moves via pipelines.
And again, if you focus
on the big numbers,
you see Russian gas
moving into Europe.
And you see gas from the
Middle East, importantly,
moving to Asia.
But it's not moving by
pipeline across China.
It's moving liquefied by tanker.
There are some exports
from Indonesia,
some exports from Australia,
and a little gas into the US.
Big imports from Canada,
relatively speaking,
and I guess we
export to Mexico--
again, just because we can.
That's got to be just geography.
As I say, most of
it's by pipeline.
If you look at the output,
Russia is the big producer.
Russia produces 15% of the
natural gas in the world.
The Middle East together--
and it's really hard to see
it on this lousy picture--
produces 14%.
Reserves-- once again,
Russia is producing
a lot out of its 24%
of the world reserves.
The Middle East has 40%
proved reserves as of 2010.
The US had 5%.
This picture will change because
you see now, with shale gas,
estimates of recoverable gas--
not yet a proven reserve--
are anomalous.
So as exploration adds
to this inventory,
the US number will rise.
I don't know if the Middle East
has shale or Russia has shale.
China will show
up on the picture.
And if they allow drilling
in Poland, Poland, I'm told,
has a fair amount.
So that picture will change.
This is just with
a proved reserve.
But again, it's the
same picture as oil.
The one exception-- and I
guess this is a little bit
interesting--
you'll see the share of the
Middle East actually rises.
Not only does it rise in
absolute value, of course,
it rises in share.
And you will recall when
we did the climate change
negotiations, you were
in Qatar or "cutter"
as it's sometimes called.
That's their discovery of their
enormous natural gas reserves.
That's one formerly
poor, little country
finding it is sitting on an
enormous amount of natural gas,
and that's the Middle
Eastern change primarily.
Other people are
developing, of course,
but that's what's
going on there.
And as I say, that North
America, which I guess
is this one--
that will change over time
because we have a lot of gas.
But it's not yet proven,
not yet proved reserves.
It's oh, my god, look at what's
almost certainly down there,
but it's not--
We have a lot of pipelines.
This is how you
move natural gas.
This is just a map of
the US pipeline network.
And here we are at the end
of the straw, as they say.
So every so often,
there isn't enough gas
coming up to
Massachusetts-- most
of the time, not a problem.
You hear about the Henry Hub.
Well, if you follow
this business,
you hear about Henry Hub.
Henry Hub is about there.
There's a lot of
offshore pipelines,
but Henry Hub is in
southern Louisiana
a little bit east of the center.
And it's where something
like 13 pipelines come in--
nine interstate and
four intrastate.
And when you hear
the Henry Hub price,
pricing of natural gas
in wholesale markets
is mostly the price at the
Henry Hub plus transport cost.
So people do futures
markets based on Henry Hub,
and then you add
in transport costs.
You do a contract on a Henry
Hub price and a transport.
So when I say gas moves
mainly by pipelines,
it moves in the US
a lot by pipelines.
You can also tell by the
pipelines where it comes from.
At the moment, it comes
from Louisiana, Texas.
It comes from offshore.
That's northern Louisiana.
That's Oklahoma.
And that's mainly it.
That will change.
It's coming from North
Dakota, where you
don't see a lot of pipelines.
It's relatively easy to build
gas pipelines in this country,
so they will be built.
Natural gas-- these are prices.
So this is the US
Henry Hub price
in red, the UK price,
the Japanese price,
and the German price.
You will see in recent years,
at least, there's the US price,
there's the UK price,
there is the German price,
which is a Russian price, and
there's the Japanese price.
So you can sort
of see why there's
some interest in this country
in exporting natural gas.
If you can actually
produce it for that price
and sell it to Japan, you
might eat half the difference
in transport, but
that's a huge margin.
So we have built terminals to
import natural gas that are now
being converted to export.
Well, they're trying to
convert them to export.
And here is a historical
price series that cuts off.
I thought this was a defect
of the way I got the picture,
but I now see in terms of the
flow here, it's a feature.
This cuts off about 2009.
We will explore the
rest on Wednesday.
You see the price is volatile.
That's a doubling
in less than a year.
That's a doubling.
That's almost a tripling.
That's another doubling.
So historically, gas price
volatility not quite as
bad as oil volatility,
but it's been there.
We'll see going
forward the picture
looks a little different.
We'll see whether that's
likely to continue.
You've been very
quiet after oil,
so I'll need to see if you
have questions or comments.
Because I don't want to
go into fracking today.
I'll wait till Wednesday.
Comments on gas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So gas tends
to occur with oil
as in wherever there's
an oil reserve they're
surrounded by gas or something?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Often.
Not always, but often.
Because these are fossils.
These are dead
dinosaurs and trees.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of companies
are oil and gas companies,
often, not coal
and gas companies?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, because they
tend to be co-located.
There is gas.
There's coalbed methane.
There is some joint
occurrence of gas and coal.
Historically, coal
companies ignored it,
because it's a little
tricky to recover.
There's more recovery
now of coalbed methane.
And the percentages differ
a lot from place to place--
oil versus gas.
In Qatar, for instance,
it's almost all gas.
In some places it's
almost all oil.
But there tends to be--
well, the Middle East
has lots of both.
So in that broad sense,
that they co-locate.
Yeah, Andrew.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One thing that you mentioned
was about the price.
Does it track, or did it
used to track oil price
at all, natural gas, I mean?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, that's a good point.
It doesn't here.
Back in the day when oil was
used to generate electricity,
you had so-called "substitution"
at the burner tip,
that the ability of power plants
to switch between natural gas
and oil tended to link
their prices pretty tightly.
The Russian price to Europe--
prices, since it's not just one
price-- but the Russian prices
to Europe tend to be linked
by contract to the oil price.
In the US, since we
don't generate much--
we don't effectively know
electricity from oil--
there's some, but it's
not much, old diesels--
that burner tip
substitution doesn't link
and there's no contractual link.
Now, per unit of energy,
gas is enormously cheaper
than oil in the US--
enormously cheaper.
I'm trying to
remember the ratio.
Is it 10 to 1?
It can't be that high,
but it's pretty high.
It's a big difference.
So even if you could burn
oil in a power plant,
you wouldn't today.
And you haven't for a long
time because of the price
difference.
AUDIENCE: The other
question would
be [INAUDIBLE] you mentioned
that there is no world
market for natural gas.
And I'm just
wondering, and I was
going to mention that people
link it to oil, which doesn't
make a lot of sense to me.
I was wondering, and
you mentioned something
that it's about--
we might see a world
market for natural gas.
What are the reasons that
they have not [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Cost, transport cost.
AUDIENCE: Because I would
assume just because you have--
the technology is there and
you see the differences--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, the technology
is there, but to
liquefy the gas--
to compress it and
liquefy it costs money.
The tankers are expensive.
The terminal facilities
are expensive.
So that's the reason why--
Japan can import lots of gas,
but it's not a world market
in the sense of a world price.
Because the market has been
traditionally very different
from the--
North America is pipelines,
boom, boom, boom.
And that's pretty unified.
Pipelines are pretty cheap--
all things equal,
pipelines are pretty cheap.
But liquefying the stuff,
and putting it on board ship,
and moving it across the ocean
is an expensive proposition,
which is why the Asian
price has been so much
higher than the European price.
Now, as people say, suppose the
US really produces this stuff
at scale and begins to
export in quantity to Asia
to take into account
that price difference.
Just geographically,
we're in a position
to undermine Russian
pricing to Europe
and in a position to undercut
Middle Eastern pricing to Asia.
We don't have that
much gas, but we
have enough, some people
argue, to unify the world
in price terms.
Some people say that's nuts.
So it comes down to the numbers,
and how much we produce,
and is there gas in China.
If there's a lot
of gas in China,
at cost comparable
to ours, then you
begin to see world gas
prices of around $5 to $6
instead of these $12,
$13, $14 prices in Asia.
There's a possibility, but it's
not going to happen through--
well, it can happen through
LNG, but it is expensive.
It is expensive.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What's the carbon
intensity vis-a-vis oil?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Excuse me, what?
AUDIENCE: What's the carbon
intensity vis-a-vis oil?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's less
carbon intensive than oil.
It's methane.
It's CH4.
Oil tends to have
a good deal more.
Oil varies.
I can't give you a ratio.
I should be able
to, but I can't.
You can look it up.
But it's about-- the one number
that it does stick in my head
and this is because it's
a power plant number--
using natural gas in a power
plant as compared to coal
gives you about half
the CO2 emissions.
Oil will be somewhere in
between, and different grades--
Canadian heavy oil may
be more carbon intensive
than light crude
from Saudi Arabia.
I just don't know the answer,
but somewhere in between.
Anything else?
Prosper?
AUDIENCE: Is coal
gas still being
purchased internationally?
Also, are there countries
where using coal gas
is more cheaper than importing--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Importing LNG?
AUDIENCE: --natural gas?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I hate to admit
that there's something
I completely don't know,
but I don't know.
It wouldn't surprise me.
If a country has coal
supplies, doesn't have gas,
and doesn't have
good port facilities,
then it would make sense
to do coal gasification.
There are places where--
again, much of it's done--
there's talk of and some
use of gas from coal
to burn in power plants because
you're basically leaving
some of the carbon behind.
So you're getting combined
cycle efficiency, less carbon
emissions.
But whether it's in use
at scale, I don't know.
The South Africans were doing--
they were mostly
doing liquid fuel.
I don't know that they-- hmm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, they built one.
It may still be
working actually,
but I thought that was
mostly for liquids.
AUDIENCE: There's a
company here, [INAUDIBLE],,
that actually [INAUDIBLE].
That's pretty much just
the only place [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's
doing coal gasification,
but that's not for use as gas.
It's probably for use in
electricity generation,
or is it for use in gas?
AUDIENCE: Right now,
most of [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
electricity, so yeah, I
can't rule out it being
put in pipes for heating
and lighting someplace, but
I don't know of any place.
Interesting question.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Yeah, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: So natural gas might
replace some coal because it's
cheaper, in some instances.
Will it replace oil in
a transportation sector
or is that just out of
the question for a while?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
that's a good question.
One of the optional
readings for Wednesday
is this MIT Future
of Natural Gas Study.
And one of the things they
investigate is exactly that.
If you think about one
of the issues that arises
is energy density.
Gasoline is just
this marvelous stuff
because in a
relatively small space,
you could store enough
energy to move a ton
and a half vehicle 200 miles.
Gas is hard to get that kind of
density unless you liquefy it.
If you liquefy it,
of course, you've
got all this problem
of keeping it cold
and keeping the pressure.
So on the other hand, per BTU,
it's so much cheaper than oil,
than gasoline or diesel.
So there's a lot of discussion.
We will probably see,
assuming prices hold,
we'll probably see a lot of
use of gas in urban fleets.
You already see some, because a
bus fleet or a taxi fleet where
you don't have to travel far
from a place you can refuel,
you refuel often.
And it's worth it if it's
just a whole lot cheaper
to refuel a couple of
times a day to save money.
There are no technical
problems building engines
to run on the stuff.
That happens now.
You can buy cars that
can run on natural gas.
It's just the refueling
infrastructure
and the cruising range
is a problem for cars.
People are talking.
So urban fleets, yeah, delivery
vehicles, yeah, taxi cabs,
yeah.
There's talk about using
liquefied natural gas
for long-haul trucks where
you don't need that many
fueling stations.
You need them on
the main routes.
So instead of having to have
them all over the country,
you can have a few
at certain intervals.
And because you're
hauling a lot,
it may be worthwhile to put
all that stuff on a truck.
Again, the world divides
into those people
who think it's the natural
next step and those people who
think that's crazy.
And I don't know the answer.
We'll find out.
It's interesting.
And again, what drives
it is the enormous--
and I'll get the
number for next time--
the anomalous per-BTU difference
between gas and oil right now.
And we'll see gas prices
are probably unsustainably
low at the moment.
But they're going to stay
low for a while, I think.
OK, anything else?
Questions, comments, speeches?
All right, we'll do hydraulic
fracking, the new world
of natural gas, the
boomtown in North Dakota,
earthquakes in Ohio, flammable
drinking water in New York
State, and all of those
good stories next time.
And we'll figure
out how to solve it.